hey guys my name is Jessica watching
games what news and last Friday I told
you Eddie would be a new top 5 post but
some of you guys thought I meant he was
replacing me for daily hosting just to
clarify i'm still here and i'll never
leave you here's me first up there's no
need to crack out Halle Berry's unique
condition of catwoman to get your fixed
as a new injustice to video featuring
the feeling super hero has arrived
catwoman otherwise known as Selena Kyle
looks to be a super speedy addition to
the roster the new clip shows how
zipping around the stage with in hand
clawing at Harley Quinn she also summons
a feline companion to distract her
opponents which is hilarious but fair
that would be super distracting in the
middle of a superhero battle as you can
imagine her whip also gets a whole lot
of use aiding her in closing the
distance between her foes so she can
take them on up close Catwoman also
appears to make use of her motorbike in
some particularly brutal moves ouch as
for where Selena will fall in injustice
to story Warner Brothers have said
Batman is still struggling to figure out
whether or not Catwoman is on his side
in the fight against the society next up
a few of you guys have great eyes for
space guns that don't exist as some
people have noticed there's a gun in
Mass Effect Andromeda that appears in
cutscenes but not in the actual game and
you want it because of course you do the
gun in question was revealed as the x5
ghost and it currently isn't in the game
but that could change in response to a
Twitter query lead designer and Fraser
said it was an early idea that became
prop that doesn't exist as a functional
gun in the game that said several folks
seem interested in it so we're
investigating the possibility of turning
the prop into a usable gun for a future
patch see there you go you're changing
face writer will at least have another
cool guns turn around
finally the new spiderman game coming
from insomniac will be arriving this
year according to marble Ryan Perry goes
vice president and executive editor of
Marvel digital media said during a live
stream there's even more on the horizon
for 2017 like spider-man coming to
playstation 4 and marvel vs capcom
infinite coming to xbox one ps4 and pc
not sure we went to drop that one or not
but it's exciting news given we've been
hanging out for a relief window since
the Spidey game was announced during
last year's e3 on the movie front Marvel
and Sony Pictures partnered up to
deliver July spider-man homecoming which
looks great so it makes sense the game
may come out around the film release if
you've forgotten insomniacs take on
Spidey we'll put the spotlight on a more
experienced Peter Parker as he fights
crime in New York hit that subscribe
button if you liked today's video and
want to see more be sure to head back to
gamespot if you want to catch up on all
the latest news and features and I'll
see you tomorrow